GMAIL’S POPULARITY:
Gmail’s popularity is falling off a cliff.
In September of 2021, they controlled 35.25%
of the market.
But by October of 2022, they only controlled
27.95% of the market.
This means that within these 13 months, Gmail’s
market share fell by a whopping 7.3%.
This might not seem like a large amount at
first glance, but it is when you consider
that basically everyone with an internet connection
uses email.
There’s estimated to be about 4.26 billion
email users worldwide.
So, this means that Gmail either lost 306
million users or the people who are opening
new email accounts are choosing the other
email clients by far.
It’s probably some sort of combination of
both, but why?
Ever since gmail launched, the consensus has
been that gmail is the go to email client.
Whether we’re talking about personal use,
business use, or fake email use, gmail has
been the bomb.
I would even argue that some of the other
email clients have had a negative stigma surrounding
them especially yahoo and hotmail.
So, how did Gmail go from being the go to
email service to having losing a fifth of
their market share within a year.
THE APPEAL OF GMAIL:
To understand why Gmail is losing so much
market share, we’ll first have to understand
why they were so popular in the first place.
And for this, we’ll have to go back to April
fools day of 2004.
If you didn’t know, Gmail was actually launched
as kind of a joke.
In fact, Sundar Pichai, the current CEO of
Google, was interviewing with Google at the
time.
And when interviewers asked him about his
thoughts on Gmail, even he thought that it
was just an April Fool’s Day joke.
The main reason that this theory was so popular
was because Gmail’s offering was simply
laughibly absurd.
At the time, Yahoo and Hotmail offered 2MB
of storage and 5MB of storage respectively.
So, when Google came out with 1 GB of storage
on April Fools Day, people assumed that it
was surely a joke.
But, April Fools Day came and left and Gmail
was still operational.
This definitely caught people by surprise,
but Google was just getting started.
In 2005, they would increase the storage to
two GB, and in 2007, they would increase the
storage to four GB.
Very quickly, Gmail went from being a joke
to being the most desirable email client.
I don’t think I have to tell you the horrors
of trying to ensure that your entire email
archive is less than 2 or 5 MB.
But, storage was just the first of many advantages
of Gmail.
Gmail also boasted the best spam filters,
the best UI, convenient grouping, and ability
to actually search through your email.
Yes, the other popular services didn’t even
let you search.
But, while everyone wanted Gmail, not very
many people could actually get it and this
brings us to the second appeal of Gmail which
was scarcity.
Here’s the thing, offering these crazy storage
spaces that were magnitudes above the competition
turned out to be extremely hard.
So, they had to heavily limit the number of
users that used the service.
For most companies, this would’ve been a
major scaling bottleneck, but Google actually
made it an advantage by making Gmail invite
only.
People could only open a gmail account if
they were invited by someone who already had
a gmail account.
So, if you had a Gmail account, you were very
much the cool kid in the friend group.
It wasn’t till nearly 3 years after the
initial launch that Google made Gmail available
to everyone.
By this point, most people who didn’t yet
have a Gmail account were dying to switch,
so Gmail’s marketshare continued skyrocketing.
It wasn’t just everyday people who craved
Gmail either.
Google was very much getting schools and institutions
on board as well, once again thanks to their
features.
For institutions, Google offered custom domain
names, zero scheduled downtime for maintenance,
30 GB of storage up to unlimited storage based
on your plan, and 24/7 phone and email support.
Once again, Google blew out the competition
out of the water, so switching was a no brianer.
But, this was basically the end of the era
of voluntary Gmail adoption.
While Gmail was indeed the superior choice,
much of the adoption that followed in the
2010s was forced adoption.
FORCED ADOPTION:
For people who had already bought into the
Google ecosystem, Google’s strategies throughout
the 2010s probably seemed completely harmless.
But, for the people who didn’t buy into
their ecosystem, well it was definitely a
pain in the neck.
What Google started doing was merging all
of their platforms and requiring that you
have a single Google account for all of them.
This probably doesn’t seem like a big deal
today, but back in the day, people got pretty
heated about this.
And likely the biggest culprit was Google+.
If you’re not familiar with Google+, I don’t
blame you because it ended up being a massive
failure.
Google+ was basically Google’s attempt at
growing their own social media platform and
competing against Facebook.
It seems harmless at first glance, but the
problem was that instead of enticing people
to join Google+ because of its features, Google
forced Google+ down people’s throats.
For example, in 2011, Google modified the
Gmail account creation process such that you
had to create a Google+ profile, and this
was the case up until 2014.
I think you can see why this would be annoying,
but this wasn’t even close to being their
worst infraction.
Likely their worst infraction was their policy
regarding YouTube comments.
In 2013, YouTube mandated that people must
have Google+ accounts if they wanted to leave
comments.
For obvious reasons, people were enraged and
even YouTube’s cofounder Jawed Karim would
call out google.
Jawed would post quote “Why the f do I need
a Google+ account to comment on a video?”
Despite all the backlash, Google wouldn’t
untie YouTube and Google+ up until 2015.
While Google+ was no doubt the worst offender,
the same fundamental argument was applicable
to Gmail accounts as well.
Google made it so that you needed a Gmail
account if you wanted to do anything else
on Google.
Do you want to use Google Drive?
Well, you’re gonna need a Gmail.
Do you want to a YouTube account?
Do you want to download apps from the play
store?
Well, you’re gonna need a Gmail.
The funniest part was that this monopoly extended
outside of Google’s services as well.
I’m sure you’re all familiar with the
“login with Google” feature.
While this feature is on doubt super convenient,
it just further strengthened the Google monopoly
and forced more people to get Gmails even
if their use case had nothing to do with using
Gmail for email.
A similar case could be made for the education
side of Gmail as well.
If universities wanted to run Google Ads or
roll out schoolwide Google calendars, they
needed a Google account, and they needed all
their students to have Google accounts as
well.
Now, technically, many Google features are
available without having an account, but we
all know that the services are way better
if you have an account.
Trying to use Google’s services without
an account is like trying to use airpods with
a Windows computer.
It works, but it’s not all that great.
THE TURNING TIDE:
All of this brings us to where we are today.
Google has become one of the most dominant
email clients in the world by leveraging features,
scarcity, and forced adoption, but their dominance
is slowly started to fade away.
So, what’s happening?
Well the answer is pretty simple.
Google is running out of trump cards.
Let’s start with features.
One of Gmail’s original selling features
was their massive storage, but the competition
has not only caught up, they’ve actually
overtaken Google.
Take Outlook for example.
Outlook offers 15 GB of storage just for their
email alone, and you get an additional 5 GB
through OneDrive.
So, Gmail is by no means leagues ahead of
the competition anymore.
Moving onto Gmail’s second selling factor
of scarcity, well no one really thinks that
having Google account is cool anymore.
It’s basically just the norm and everyone
already has one.
This also makes it extremely difficult for
Google to force more adoption because there’s
really no one left to convince.
Something else that we should mention is that
Google was never really the ideal choice for
students or professionals because you can’t
leverage Microsoft office as much.
The reason that many schools and universities
embraced Google docs, slides, and sheets is
because they made collaboration extremely
convenient.
But, if you put the convenience and collaboration
aspects aside, there’s no question that
Microsoft office is the superior service.
And over the past 10 years, Microsoft has
very much made strides with their own online
office products and collaboration features.
Microsoft Office online is actually free,
but that doesn’t even matter to institutions
because they usually already have a bunch
of office 365 subscriptions anyway.
So, many institutions are switching back to
Outlook to create synergies between email,
cloud storage, and Microsoft Office.
We should also mention that while schools
and universities very much embraced Google,
companies never did.
In fact, nearly 196,000 companies in the US
use outlook while only 4,400 use Gmail.
Another catalyst that has stolen market share
away from Gmail is Apple’s recent Mail Privacy
Protection program.
This program makes it harder for email marketers
to track down your IP address and your mail
activity.
And in age where everyone is worried about
juggernauts like Google and Facebook collecting
your data, it’s not surprising that people
are taking every chance to project themselves.
This is made even easier by the fact that
you don’t have to do anything to take advantage
of this program.
In fact, it would be easier to take advantage
of this program than not take advantage of
it.
All you have to do is use the inbuilt mail
app on iPhones instead of downloading the
Gmail app.
And while people have been weary of the iPhone
email app for years, it seems like this new
feature is very much pushing people towards
it, and we can see this in the market share
data.
In September of 2021, Apple had 50% market
share, but today they have nearly 60% market
share.
And I suspect that this will only grow with
time as people become more aware of the importance
of data protection.
THE FUTURE OF GMAIL:
At the end of the day, Gmail is by no means
dying or becoming irrelevant.
You very much still need a Gmail account to
surf the internet freely.
But it does seem like people are using other
services for email more and more frequently.
Some of the surface levels reasons for this
are that competing email clients have caught
up in terms of features, they have better
integration with Microsoft Office, and Google
has basically just reached market saturation.
But, if we look beyond that, it appears that
we’re seeing a larger trend towards privacy.
People are more aware than ever how these
companies are able to offer their services
for free and how they really make money.
For example, here’s all the data the Google
is able to collect just off of Gmail.
It appears that Apple has caught onto this
consumer awareness and they’re very much
framing their business with this mind.
They’re positioning themselves as the big
tech company that doesn’t collect data.
This can be seen with their “Ask Not To
Track” feature and their mail privacy protection
program.
It’s not just Apple who’s jumping onto
this trend either.
In the messaging space, we have Signal and
in the social media space, we have BeReal.
While these services offer completely different
functionality, their core appeal is the identical:
Erasing the bad aspects of big tech.
And given that Google already doesn’t have
the much room to grow, I suspect that Gmail’s
popularity will simply continue to trend downwards,
but that’s just what I think.
Which email client is your favorite?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you hope this trend leads
to more transparency and openness regarding
Google’s services.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.